at a field encampment in the southern
part of Phu Yen province troops of the
101st Airborne Division prepare for
operation Geronimo phase one being
launched on the last day of October is
to be a night mission the area where the
Search and Destroy mission will be
carried out is discussed as a recon
platoon is brief terrain features are
pointed out on a map equipment to be
taken on the sweep is given a final
check black greasepaint will help to
hide the troopers from enemy eyes in the
darkness
finally the airborne troopers move out
during the night the area around Tweed
hua is searched and scattered enemy
resistance is met now on the morning of
November 1 the airborne units begin
working their way back toward the
landing zone the probing continues on
the way out bundles of clothing and
other personal belongings left behind by
the fleeing Viet Cong or examine 17 of
the enemy were killed during the night
long sweep bags of rice also left behind
by the VC are opened and the contents
destroyed in a brief rest period some
men try to sleep while others just sit
down somewhere now in full daylight the
night operators file out of the jungle
and reach the open field where the
helicopters will pick them up a smoke
signal brings the troop lifts choppers
and the leg weary jungle fighters begin
the 64 kilometres light back to their
camp
at Kong Shan weapons taken from the
enemy during the night are put on
display operation Geronimo phase one has
been successful
a daily ground support mission is about
to get underway
as two gunships of the 48 aviation
company take off from their base at toir
today the 23rd of October will be
different 35 kilometers north of their
base the gunships are given an urgent
new assignment an army o1 spotter plane
is down gunships of Joker platoon are to
assist in the search and provide cover
for the medevac chopper the wrecked
aircraft is spotted within 30 minutes
and the two armed choppers circle the
area dust off arrives sliding downward
toward the crash site to pick up the
injured pilot the gunships continue to
cover a suspicious movement is seen
below as the wrecked aircraft is set
afire the gunships will refuel at weon
then return for a better look at the
area where the crash occurred landing at
we on the refuelling commences at once
while the two aircraft commanders
quickly discuss the plan of action then
the gunships of Joker platoon are once
again in the air
alert to the possibility of enemy troop
movement in the area the sector is
closely scrutinized and photographs are
taken of all suspicious localities then
ground fire is encountered the gunships
go into action raking the edge of the
jungle with machine-gun fire as each
helicopter makes a pass
next time around the enemy position is
hit with rocket fire the target marked
by smoke bombs is again blasted with
machine guns and all ground fire ceases
it's all over and the Joker's go home
halfway between Phuket and Hammond
airfield lies a holding camp for
Vietnamese refugees established by the
first Air Cavalry Division its primary
function is to take care of civilians
our fruited from their villages during
operation Irving male refugees construct
permanent type dwellings with materials
supplied by the 1st Cav
although the camp will be their home
only until they can be moved to
resettlement villages however for the
time being many still live in tents
anything of value which they can salvage
is put aside for their future homes
meanwhile as they wait to begin new
lives each family cooks and eats its
meals out of doors during the month of
October approximately 2,800 displaced
civilians have been given refuge here in
addition to the livestock which will
help them begin anew a short distance
away nearer Phu cot at a compound
established by a United States MP
company prisoners taken during operation
Irving are given an ID check as soon as
they are checked in these Viet Cong
captured by the first Air Cavalry
Division are taken to one of the
compound buildings for interrogation a
u.s. lieutenant and an R of an
interpreter team up to interrogate one
of the prisoners a wounded prisoner has
his head bandaged by a medic while he is
put through an intensive interrogation
to make certain he is a Vietcong and to
exact information that will assist the
1st Cav in its Search and Destroy
operations as soon as the prisoners are
confirmed as be seized and their
interrogation is completed they are led
into the wire enclosed compound where
they are kept under tight security
this Hut serves as their sleeping
quarters although only 20 are being held
here at the moment as many as 400 a day
have been brought in during operation
Irving they line up outside for dinner
on the left are kyu hoís who surrendered
voluntarily in the center is a North
Vietnamese regular and on the right are
VC guerrillas the bill of fare consists
of familiar hot rice and unfamiliar sea
rations some eat only the rice prepared
by local Vietnamese women while others
embarking on an entirely new adventure
in eating bravely struggle with the sea
rations
the Mekong River and the monsoon season
add up to an inescapable fact of life in
the Mekong Delta flooded farmlands
villages and cities in Jo dot province
190 kilometers southwest of Saigon the
annual flood damage is much worse than
usual this year with their homes
virtually afloat
thousands of inhabitants have had to
flee to higher ground in these
communities some as close as 1800 meters
to the Cambodian border waiting on Main
Street is a seasonal way of life US
military vehicles trying to help are
bogged down US Special Forces personnel
stationed in the Delta team up with the
Navy and US aid to fly emergency medical
supplies and food to the refugees
thousands of typhoid and cholera shots
will be administered to prevent
epidemics the rescue crews discuss
loading problems since helicopters must
take off carrying an overload of as much
as 500 pounds the floodwaters came last
year and will almost surely come next
and as long as they're in the area
US Army personnel will do all they can
to help
another contingent of the Philippine
civic action group arrives at tiny nan
the 19th of October here 80 kilometers
northwest of Saigon the new hospital
group is greeted by other members of the
Civic action team who had arrived during
September several nurses are among those
who are being greeted the village head
man joins in the hearty welcome for the
nurses and other medical personnel work
on the tiny station hospital was begun
by the Filipino engineers soon after
their arrival this building one of three
in the hospital complex will house the
outpatient clinic and dispensary the
temporary dental clinic already services
some 300 patients per day most work is
extraction at the adjoining dispensary
patients are registered in and medics
take care of them a high percentage of
the patients are children nearby the old
tiny school is undergoing remodeling and
expansion improved educational
facilities ranked high on the program of
activities the @nationals assists in the
work at the village of Thai Binh a short
distance away food is distributed to the
needy residence by one of the Philippine
civic action teams on the outskirts
members of the security battalions stand
guard the village is located in war zone
see the 29th of October is a banner day
for the people of Fuquan village 32
kilometres north of Saigon they are
celebrating the start of a new road
building project civilian dignitaries
gather from near and far for the
occasion flower garlands go to the
Filipino engineers who will build the
road
the commander of the Philippine civic
action group explains the construction
program and pledges assistance for the
district a Filipino engineer and a
Vietnamese highway worker symbolized the
United construction effort as a parade
of road building equipment is staged by
the Philippine civic action group during
the ceremonies the Philippine commander
bids farewell to the villagers and the
new civic action project is officially
launched
despite an attempt by the Vietcong to
turn celebration into tragedy the
Vietnamese national day parade is held
right on schedule in Saigon on November
1st premier key chief of state - and
other high-ranking dignitaries take
their place on the reviewing stand the
day's events get underway with a
military flyby only an hour before
terrorists fired several recoilless
rifle shells into the area but they fell
short and caused little damage
Vietnamese infantry troops carrying
their unit colors proudly lead the
parade down song not Boulevard as a
crowd estimated at nearly 100,000 looks
on loudest applause of the day is won by
the colorful and primitive Mountain yard
tribesmen of the Central Highlands and
their elaborately decorated elephants
not to be outdone the montón yard tribes
women also put in an appearance
another popular group is a band of 500
former Vietcong who came over to fight
on the government side a crack military
drill team makes an impressive showing
as does a Royal Australian Army Band
leading a combined company of Aussie and
New Zealand forces Vietnamese
paratroopers demonstrate their freefall
techniques they are followed by elements
of the Philippine civic action battalion
just about every type of Allied fighting
unit in Vietnam makes an appearance even
a scout dog platoon the hour-long parade
climaxes 18 days of celebration
commemorating the overthrow of the GM
regime in 1963 and the establishment of
a new republic but even more it
demonstrates once again the
determination of both Vietnamese and
allies to defend the independence of
that Republic
on the morning of 4 november disaster
strikes throughout northern Italy when
recent Alpine snows too quickly melted
by warm reigns sends torrents of water
cascading madly down the mountainside a
normally dry creek bed running through
the resort of tierra de primero
is suddenly transformed into a raging
river causing landslides and destroying
homes and bridges in a courageous
attempt to divert the rampaging river
the people of the town band together to
form a human chain for passing rocks
along during the construction of a dam
for three days the onslaught continues
all roads are washed out communication
disrupted totally isolated the community
exists without heat electricity or
drinking water responding to a plea for
help
helicopters of the US Army CTA aviation
company stationed near Verona begin a
shuttle of needed supplies into thieriot
deep reme air all including blankets
food and tools known as the angels of
mercy because of their aid during other
disasters the Army aviators evacuate
many of the injured as well with at
least seven dead
scores injured and damaged running into
millions of dollars residents believe it
will take many years before the tourist
resort returns to normal
sealing right at home in the rarefied
atmosphere of the world's highest
commercial airport astronauts Richard
Gordon and Neil Armstrong arrived in La
Paz Bolivia to continue their goodwill
tour of Latin America after meeting
local officials the astronauts and their
party begin a 45-minute descent from the
airport which lies over two and a half
miles above sea level in the Andes along
the route they are greeted by thousands
of cheering Bolivian
Lieutenant Commander Gordon flew with
Gemini 11 which set the altitude record
while Armstrong's Gemini 9 was the first
to accomplish docking in space in the
center of town an official ceremony is
held during which the astronauts place a
commemorative wreath at the Statue of
Simon Bolivar Liberator and founder of
Bolivia then they wade into the crowd
meeting as many people as possible
before departing on the next leg of
their 10 nation tour several days later
it's much the same story as the
astronauts reach Panama City last stop
on their busy agenda after a motorcade
through the city the astronauts and
their wives are welcomed at City Hall
the mayor in typical Latin fashion
greets them warmly they in turn present
him with a scale model of their Gemini
spacecraft as well as a color photo of
the capsule as it orbited the earth next
stop is cathedral plaza where the
astronauts accompanied by American
ambassador Adair once again placed a
commemorative wreath this time beneath
the bust of Panama's founder and first
president dr. Manuel Amador Guerrero as
the hectic three-week tour winds up the
astronauts look forward to the more
leisurely business of piloting
spacecraft
this prototype of the uh-1 universal
particle separator is being installed in
a uh-1d helicopter developed by the Army
Materiel Command it is designed to
reduce erosion of the t53 engine used to
power the uh-1b uh-1b 540 and the uh-1d
after the particle separator is
installed the primary test aircraft
takes off at Fort Rucker Alabama and
aims directly for the first test area
sand and dust are the primary causes of
the engineer ocean which is seriously
affecting helicopter operations in
Vietnam at the second test area the
particle separator is tested for its
effectiveness in preventing ingestion of
long blades of grass which cause engine
failures when they become lodged in the
inlet guide vanes this grass is trapped
in the separator throughout the tests
temperature sensitive paint supplied to
the drive shaft are checked to see if
installation of the particle separator
reduces air cooling the third test area
provides dust conditions more typical of
operational flights in South Vietnam
under normal conditions the t53 engine
has a time between overhaul of 1100
hours in unprepared dusty areas in
Vietnam t53 engines have required
replacement in as little as 300 hours if
the uh-1 Universal particle separator
proves itself under these varied
conditions it is expected that engine
failure in Vietnam will be greatly
reduced
the XM 166 a full track air defense
vehicle represents the marriage of a
standard m42 twin forty millimeter gun
turret mounted on an m5 48 chassis in
tests conducted on Madonna on arranged
El Paso Texas the XM 166 is put through
its paces the weapon fires that towed
and fixed ground targets the XM 166
proves its maneuverability in
cross-country tests combat loaded with
five men aboard the vehicle weighs
29,000 pounds half the weight of the
present M 42 the current tests reflect
firing damage to the operators cab
equipment and tie-down belts it is
expected that these deficiencies will be
corrected put through a series of
stability tests with hydraulic system
stabilizers in on and off positions the
XM 166 displays a fine degree of
stability when all tests have been
completed and evaluated it is expected
that the XM 166 will replace the M 42
and provide error defense with an air
droppable amphibious full track vehicle
and at the same time represented dollar
savings since the chassis itself is
presently in the army inventory
you